whoever the uh that'll be
that'll be representative of uh whatever
the people were feeling
or believing at that specific time and
so the justices
actually are if if you just
get your head around that the justices
are
representatives of the people
this is change my mind where we
rationalize our positions
on controversial issues today is
installment two
on confirming amy coney barrett and this
circus peter mcconnell and the
republican senate
majority have no right to fill it it's
just
appalling it is you calling republican
senators and telling them enough is
enough
nothing about this today is normal this
is not
normal are you and joe biden going to
pack the court if judge amy coney
barrett is confirmed
this hearing should have been postponed
and you're certainly not going to
understand forces outside of this room
who are
pulling strings and causing the puppet
theater to react
you agree with justice scalia's view
that roe was wrongly
decided gotta ask you about packing the
court well sir don't the voters deserve
to know
no they don't disagree i'm not gonna
play his game well all right then we've
heard from them but i want to hear from
you
do you think there's any legal or
constitutional reason to not confirm
amy coney barrett maybe even a moral one
what's the best argument that you've
heard
either way on either side of the aisle
let me know in the comments below
now let's get to it first we have a
lovely conversation with the fetching
samantha now
she says that she's new to studying
politics but she seems to have an open
mind
let's hear her thoughts samantha hi
samantha can you shake hand no
elbow just in the placement do you need
to wear a mask
okay all right there we go okay samantha
do you mind stepping in a little bit
because this is our
our legal boundary where we're allowed
to actually speak
sorry masks don't fit my face very well
because i have what my friend calls
famous guy head i have a giant noggin
it's mostly filled with some kind of i'm
told
plasma-like fluid but i'm not entirely
sure
so samantha i don't know how familiar
you are we've been on this campus a few
times before
but the idea changed my mind is to uh
and you seem chipper enough we've had
pretty productive discussions to
rationalize
our positions on controversial topics so
um
yeah today's topic i see no reason why
we shouldn't fill the seats in the
supreme court
with amy coney barrett i have not heard
anything even close to a convincing
argument today
uh but if you think that there's
something i'm missing uh samantha you're
welcome to change my mind
um i'm not gonna lie i um
haven't really read much about her i've
heard of course like um
a few things not much just because i've
been really busy with midterms but i
know i need to catch up which is
important but um
in my personal opinion i feel like we
should wait for when the election's over
to put another person in the supreme
court just because um
that person will be like sharing a lot
of the same views that probably the
president
has as far as like the black lives
matter matter and all cops are a bad
kind of situation which i don't really
personally agree with but all cops are a
bad
situation but of course with all um
black lives matter could you also speak
up a little ikea yeah
i'm so sorry i'm sorry guys can we i
just i can't hear at all i hate to i
know
next time we'll try and bring some
speakers but i i she has a very
pretty soft voice but i can't hear right
now i'm sorry could you repeat that for
me i'm sorry
yeah sorry um where's my train of
thought
that's okay no one will fault you for it
i interrupted them but hopefully it'll
make it easier
no you're totally good um so
what was i saying sorry i lost my train
of thought you said something again i
heard something about black lives matter
yeah so
it got really quiet that's okay that's
okay so now they'll listen to us that's
fine oh that's scary
oh it's not scary well basically um that
person will be part of the supreme court
which is like they will say
they'll share all the presidential like
views i guess for
stuff like um black lives matter and the
view of
if all cops are bad which i don't
personally agree with but i do agree
with the black lives matter part because
of course not all cops are bad there are
some bad cops that are in
the criminal justice system that we
should probably
handle well and so that person will kind
of be kind of in charge of that and
obviously biden and trump have different
views when it comes to that situation
so i feel like we should wait after this
election to see who
we think will fit best for that position
i understand and i hear this a lot today
like i feel like we should wait yeah
why do you think we should wait what's
the reasoning to we should wait
because donald trump is president
there's a republican senate yeah
there's plenty of precedent here where
yeah
you nominate as the executive and the
legislative branch either confirms or
rejects so i don't know why we don't
i feel like um there's a word again
sorry
i think that we should wait because
there's only a few days left
until like the actual day comes to where
we figure out who our next president is
and whether it is trump and we keep um
that person then he can like put another
person on but if we decide to change
views
on what we are today as far as like
putting biden as president
then he should be the one to decide
whether who gets that position well
there aren't a few days left though
there are many months
left and there's certainly been many
months left since he uh
appointed since he nominated donald
trump nominated acb
so again it's not like there are a few
days left there are many months left he
is president for four years according to
ruth bader ginsburg that's his job he
doesn't cease being president
so with months left barack obama
nominated merrick garland right of
course merrick garland was not confirmed
by the senate because it was republican
senate
donald trump nominated acb and of course
it's a republican senate so it's very
likely that she'll be confirmed
um what are you basing that on and i
hear this a lot of people says we feel
like we should wait until the next
election but i'm not hearing any
justification from people
and that's where i wonder how much of
this opinion is instilled by and i don't
say this to be patronizing
but instilled in people by the media
because there's no precedent
there's no reasoning there's no
constitutionality behind the idea that
we need to wait
yeah i definitely i'm not gonna lie like
i
have a very open mind so you probably
will change my mind but yeah media does
play like a big
part of it and i feel like a lot of
media that at least i've seen
has been more on the like side of we
should wait
and a lot of like um we refer to that as
media yeah so i appreciate that you
acknowledge that let me ask you this
okay
if the media is doing their job and this
is this is why it's not like i said it's
not an indictment on you i see a lot of
college students who
unless you're proactively seeking out
media this is what you will believe
let me ask you this from what you've
interpreted from the media
do you believe that maybe this is a
violation of decorum like it's uncommon
for a president to nominate a justice in
an election year
um i don't feel like it's uncommon
especially since what you said about
barack obama
but i don't know what i'm saying before
we sat down and spoke it seems like you
you heard the impression that it was
uncommon
um no because i'm not okay i want to
like put this out there i'm just
starting to like
get really involved with like politics
and stuff sure um so i might be new to
all of this and it's very like
fresh-brained so i might sound very dumb
to people but it's okay i'm very
old-brained
it's just a bunch of cobwebs and some
kind of a like i said viscous
plasma-like fluid in there from
ghostbusters no you're 21.
uh yeah yeah thank you very much i
appreciate it you're gonna be my
favorite change my mind guest
um so let me fill you in on this it's
happened
oh gosh the puppy no one's gonna pay
attention to us at all uh
29 times okay a president in an election
year has nominated
supreme court justice 29 times i want to
spend the same
party controlling the executive branch
and legislative uh it's been confirmed
nine out of 10 times there was one
exception because of
ethics violations but again this would
be
exactly in line with the practice as
it's existed
uh for as long as there have been
presidents appointing supreme court
justices
so i guess the question becomes now
since we're not so much talking about i
think we both agree that
constitutionally legally
there is no argument against confirming
amy coney barrett regardless of how we
feel
but considering that that's what's been
presented from the media by your own
admission
maybe do you look at it and go oh that's
that's a little irresponsible they
haven't been filling us in properly
i wouldn't really say irresponsible
because obviously the media is very
biased
but um but that is irresponsible if
they're supposed to be unbiased if
they're supposed to be
journalists yeah um
well i feel like everything has a lot of
bias whether
that we want it to or not so in our
heads we might not be like oh that's
irresponsible because
it's just like that's my opinion and a
lot of people don't see it as bias
so do you think the media that was
proactively biased
you said that they're biased do you
think they're honest about their bias
yes
really see i don't i see jake tapper and
anderson cooper and brian stelter and
chris cuomo
i see them presenting themselves as
objective journalists where everything
that you're parroting
is a talking point from their show do
you think that those people anderson
cooper chris cuomo
jake tapper brian williams do you think
they tell people hey i'm a left-wing
activist when they present the news
no they don't i feel like they don't
probably say it as much as like
presented but i feel like they
definitely know it in the back of their
mind like this is my point of view on
stuff
right yeah but as far as like presenting
it
i don't really think so okay i i agree
with you
i don't i think they know it in their
mind and i don't think they present it
to the american people
yeah and that's what i have a problem
with i think that they should be honest
about it just like i'm honest about
my point of view from the outset and i
say hey you're welcome to change my mind
but i don't lie to people to try and
convince them
to to accept my argument and that's my
problem with those journalists so
as you're getting involved in politics
and that's not mansplaining i just
happen to do the harrison ford point
get out of my table um as you're
exploring politics i would
uh encourage you to keep that in mind uh
assume that everything has a bias which
you already started off saying and i
actually think that's very encouraging
assume it
and fact check it that's the only way
you can be sure that you're getting the
proper information
yeah definitely samantha yeah thank you
samantha i appreciate it thank you so
much yeah nice to meet you nice meeting
you
nice conversation with a nice dame cute
as a button too now remember if you want
these installments to continue
please do consider joining up at mug
club at 69
annually for students veterans active
military and you get this wonderful
hand-etched mug
the full daily show not available on
youtube uncensored unfiltered along with
the entire blaze tvs catalog go to
louderwithcrowder.com mug club if not
please do subscribe and hit the
notification bell
so that you can tune in every weekday
when we broadcast live at 10 a.m eastern
next up we have a conversation with
another young student of politics an
actual poli sci
student to be clear the difference is he
knows
everything meatkit nice to meet you do
you need me to wear my mask
honestly it's whatever you're most
comfortable with i'm most comfortable
with knots absolutely absolutely
here i'll tell you i'll wear it
underneath my mouth this is like a low
budget talk show where we just like move
the mic from one person back to the
other
it is a low budget talk show that's
exactly what it is so kit kit yep
okay great actually uh one of my
favorite grappler is a guy named kit
dale he is uh very impressive it's a
cool name also
the name of a cool car so kit i don't
know how familiar you are with what we
do here
with the change of mind but i was a very
big fan for a few years oh
no okay well i'm sorry that i lost you
to the dark side um
maybe this is the dark side who knows
you could prove me wrong so today we've
been talking about
interest maybe you're a centrist yeah um
i'm kind of more center-right i guess
compared to a lot of people but i would
just say i'm to the right of attila the
han really um
i see no reason not to confirm acb right
now the hearings are going on so
uh what we discuss is it's apt to change
right so i want to make clear so no one
thinks that you've gotten something
wrong or i've gotten something wrong
because they could be talking about
something right now
hirono could be going off on a tirade
and all of a sudden everything we've
said isn't validated
but i see no reason uh to not confirm
her to the supreme court and i haven't
heard any reasoning as to
why we should but uh sorry why we should
not so you can
feel free to change my mind um well
personally just because of the
jurisdiction that went into place during
the obama administration
uh when he tried to nominate his own
supreme court justice i just don't think
uh it would be fair now i am in favor of
uh packing the quarter expanding it
because
i am a very very libertarian per i think
that
more people in government the more
direct the more direct
uh i guess is the way you could put it i
think that's better so i would be in
favor of that just because i feel like
it would represent perhaps
the um uh the populace a bit better
because i do think that
having such a low number in the supreme
court in such an important branch
the judicial branch um that could be um
perhaps negative because it could be
stacked one way or the other and i do
have my issues with the two-party system
and until a lot of those are resolved i
wouldn't feel comfortable having such
a low number of uh justices would you
mind stepping in here just a little bit
because we have to be in the range of
this table otherwise i'll be getting in
trouble oh yeah um
so i heard you say that you're a
libertarian uh yes i lean very not like
the libertarian party but i lean
in terms of political science i i tend
to lean more towards uh
say democracy than um
a republic if that makes sense okay well
then i guess yeah that's not what a
libertarian is someone who really
believes in the
extremely limited powers of government
oh oh yeah i do but what i mean is i'm
uh
i would be much more in favor of direct
democracy than perhaps our
constitutional republic well there's
there's no way to have an extremely
limited government uh
by an originalist interpretation to the
scope
exactly of the constitution which is a
libertarian interpretation yeah
absolutely
in a democracy because everything would
be settled by a vote um well so i just
want to make sure that i understand
because i don't see how it's a
libertarian point of view to add more
people to the course i don't believe
um because i believe that the population
um obviously we've seen the two-party
system change very greatly so like the
republican party
uh for a very long time uh take uh post
reagan
was very individualist leaning right
very um
you know because obviously reagan was so
influential he got the economy back up
uh he was such a personality but um
recently uh we've seen i'm just using
the republican party as an example i can
uh go to the democratic party too
um we've seen it lean a lot more towards
more um i hesitate to say i say
federalist
more federalist a bit more like uh
statist and there's a lot of things well
federalist and status are
they're two different things what i'm
saying is that so i don't understand
what you mean is it federalist or state
um
uh i misspoke i meant them uh what i
meant is that a lot more power was going
to the state recently
and i personally a lot more power is
being delegated to the state
rather than centralizing the federal
government oh no like when i say the
state i mean the political concept of a
state so like okay the central
government
and the borders that surround it okay
all right so i want to make sure you
understand because yeah if you were
saying federalist would be about
a different terminology then i probably
should because i'm using a political
science terminology i'm a little science
major
yeah um why why do we try to be fair i
think you're using them incorrectly
because federalism and statism are very
very different right um
they're antithetical i just i just miss
book there excuse me okay um but um well
i'm just trying to get an accurate read
on your opinion so
pretty much to simplify it as much as
possible i think that the more
viewpoints
uh that you can have in a in a
concentrated area the better
so because it would represent the people
a bit more perhaps uh you can have a bit
more diversity in those viewpoints
because
three democrats if they're all bernie
sanders that does not represent
all democrats obviously because jovan
got the nomination who's going to
represent the other
90 year old white guy exactly
but isn't that just politics but
can be yeah but um not really amy coney
barrett
yeah um well senators tend to be a lot
younger is
what i've noticed because it tends to
because obviously you can't just become
a president
right um but i would just um obviously
and i don't know if the person before me
brought this up uh the
uh trump has the legal a lot of the
legal rights i'm going to kneel sorry
you don't need it obviously there's some
gray area there but
for the most part legally trump can do
this um
i would not be in favor but because i
think maybe the senate started you might
never know yeah
he would be in favor of nominating i
mean he already has nominated you're
saying
legally the senate can confirm the
senate can confirm right
i would be against them doing it because
i just think that due to their past
jurisdiction most recently
with the obama administration coming to
a close uh i would not be in favor of
that
i don't understand how one affects the
other um so at the end of the obama
administration obviously tried to
nominate him to the supreme court
senate blocked it and mostly it's
because at least from what i know
of that time i was a bit young the
senate was leaning um
the senate was leaning republican as it
uh still does today
um so gosh it's hard to talk to this
thing you're right
you can pull it down if you want i'm
totally fine i mean i just was tested
negative so i can't guarantee it but
yeah so um i just feel as though
it would be un it would be i just think
it should go to
this specific decision should go to
whoever the president-elect is whether
that be donald trump
whether that be joe biden whether that
be you know kanye west i'm not really
hearing an argument for it so i'm
hearing that you would like that
um i'm not really hearing because
merrick garland i think you just made an
argument for why
amy coney barrett should be confirmed
because of america entirely because what
the senate senate's
voting on right now is whether she is
whether to appoint her or not
that would be in favor of the senate not
doing so because obviously having the
legal right to do it and being in favor
of someone doing it are two very
different things
right um and so so this is
uh cause like you see your political
science uh and so i appreciate that you
also
mentioned the three branches of
government earlier um someone got a
little testy when i mentioned them
earlier but i'm sure as you well know
many people can't name them
uh so you have the executive and you
just mentioned barack obama nominated
merrick garland that's right he uses
executive power we would both agree
appropriately yes
okay the senate did not confirm merrick
garland that's their power that they
exercise
appropriately yeah that is their now in
this scenario the executive branch
donald trump nominated a supreme court
justice correct we would both have to
agree for the sake of consistencies
two kind of libertarians authoritatively
legitimately
the senate has the same authority to
confirm or reject
legitimately yeah there's nothing
inconsistent about them confirming
that's not a split government
well that's not really what i'm arguing
what i'm arguing is that i would not be
in favor of them doing it because i
think it would be hypocritical of the
senate's argument they made
uh with obama no no their argument was
that it was a split government that's my
point their argument wasn't just that it
was an election year
the argument was that it was
unprecedented in an election year to try
and force a divided government to
confirm from what i know yes and now
um because a lot from what i know yes um
well just because of um very clearly
i think that um i believe in the three
branch system i think that checks and
balances exist for a reason
uh however i feel like a lot of what i'm
uh
a lot of what i'm again i would not be
in favor of this i don't think it's
um right to just oh i don't think it's
right to just
elect someone during an election year
when obviously
but that's what we also we've always
done it's happened many many times in
the past so
because you don't feel it's right yes
necessarily 29 times
10 10 of those times unified government
confirmed um
well again i brought back the obama
administration but the things
i'm not saying but you're saying because
we don't do this we do do this i'm
telling you we do we have historically
we don't i'm saying that we shouldn't
okay um but we do
um well sure there's a lot of things the
us government has done in the past that
i'm not in favor of
uh but obviously my bigger point is uh i
would very much be in favor of expanding
the number of justices okay so it sounds
to me like and this is kind of what i've
noticed as a pattern today and i
appreciate your uh
your uh and i wouldn't say attempt i
appreciate your legitimate uh
communication of
what i believe is a somewhat consistent
viewpoint because that's not always been
the case today absolutely it sounds like
you were saying
there is no constitutional restraint
there is no precedent there is no
violation of the quorum really you just
don't like
the fact you would prefer that they not
confirm any koni
but it sounds like we agree that it's
well within their right and authority to
do it
well yes to an extent i like it you
don't but we both agree the league on
the legality
yes they can okay so good there we go we
can get rid of that we can get rid of
that sign yes now we can look and change
to
don't pack the courts
change my mind nobody support there was
another gentleman here he talked about
packing the class absolutely you got a
still
all right um and that gentleman left uh
feeling a little bit differently than
when he came in
he came in and said that he did support
packing that joe biden should pack the
courts
so i know that you expressed this on the
outset now that i think we both found
common ground
yes and we both found i think we both
agreed where we do disagree
i think that's productive we can move on
to the idea of packing the course you
support packing the courts
absolutely because uh i uh believe in it
because
there's a lot of diverse viewpoints in
the united states and uh
especially in such a large country
where with such a with such a variety
of viewpoints and cultures i think it
would only be
it's only logical to then use that
to then use the um power of the supreme
court to represent those ideas
okay um like what kind of ideas um well
obviously there's a lot of different
kinds of republicans there's
a lot of different kinds of democrats uh
there's a lot of
people who lie somewhere in between
though they won't get elected let me
answer this but how many different kinds
of constitutions are there
um well obviously there's just one
constitution so is it your
presupposition
that the supreme court's job is to
represent the individual opinions and
viewpoints of those appointed to the
court
no but because i am under the impression
and this is just again we may disagree
it is their job to properly interpret
the intent and law of the constitution
um
well i mean yes but on the but on
another hand the only way that can be
balanced is if they represent a variety
of viewpoints
and um what i think is the larger uh
i don't understand how that's the case a
variety of viewpoints yeah i mean there
are
a variety of points in that there are
people who are left and right the uh
jude if the um supreme court was
strictly
let's strictly republican um that would
obviously offset checks and balances a
lot because the
the way that the supreme court functions
is not just as
like an individual it's a collective of
it's a collective of people whose job is
to help interpret
the law and i think that it's only fair
if you represent a diverse
variety of opinions what are when
talking about that law
well yeah but there's also a reason that
people like
that's why the voting for the senate
works the way it does that's why i voted
for the house works the way it does
it's in order to make sure that
everything is represented
because your political science major
okay absolutely so and this isn't me
doing the man i just happen to do a
harrison ford point it doesn't mean that
i'm cross with you
um let me ask you this you just
mentioned the house you just mentioned
the senate
yes what is the primary difference
between the judiciary and those
um well you said it by intent
um well obviously the supreme court's
uh job so to speak is to interpret the
law no it is not meant to be a
democratically elected
body and a body of government um supreme
court by design the supreme court
the supreme court we don't vote in the
supreme court absolutely
we vote on our representatives and then
the official representative
from that there that is a pro this is
this really matters as a political
science major maybe you haven't gotten
to this part yet
that process exists for a very specific
reason um why do you believe the process
is exclusively well the president let me
finish
exclusively this has been protected the
president has the right to nominate
and the senate has the right to confirm
or reject and
not the american public voting on
supreme court justices as they do with
the house and senate why do you believe
that's the case because it is the case
early on in what you said there's a
little bit of a contradiction
and that contradiction is that we is
that
we vote on every single specific little
uh we vote on obviously
like a vast variety of things the
president whatever oh we are a republic
we vote people to vote
for us and the president is obviously an
extension of that who are they will
appoint
who they will i'm sorry could you walk
in the owner's mind asking because if we
go beyond these barriers here you keep
walking away from me i don't bite i
can't fight with this man
i'm so sorry this paper will protect you
as it does from microscopic droplets
um yeah i know it's just because uh if
we're beyond this thing also we're
impeding traffic so i appreciate you
helping
um well you said i was inconsistent yes
because
obviously um the gov we exist in a
republic
um constitutional republicans in our as
a republic we elect people to vote
for us and the whole point of a
president being able to elect supreme
court justices
is that uh we can observe through time
that things tend to swan
swaying back and forth and back and
forth and so as a result
what will naturally happen is there will
be a balanced mix
of every single uh viewpoint that's been
held for say
the past few different presidents uh or
the past few i think terms would be
a bit more accurate because obviously a
person can serve more than one term like
more than one justice
yada yada um obviously there's
emergencies like what happened with
rutabaga ginsburg
um but the supreme court exists to
interpret the constitution and i fee
and the only fair way to do that to
interpret the constitution
really quickly around this time this guy
decided to show up and literally play
the world's tiniest sounding violin
that's not how you do it show them how
it's done
now i feel better about it all right
back to the conversation and the only
fair way to do that to interpret the
constitution
is to in my opinion is to have a
diverse variety of viewpoints not only a
diverse variety of viewpoints but those
that reflect um
the people's will which therefore
translates itself through whoever was
elected president
but no that's actually not the the role
of the supreme court and i don't
understand where i was being
inconsistent
um because you were talking about like
obviously oh we vote on certain things
and then the pres and then the president
nominates the supreme court justice
in actuality we most of the time when
we're not talking about local elections
we elect people to vote for us and those
people
impose whatever they campaign we elect
people to represent us
um they're representatives yes that's
another they don't have to pull us for
every single vote
the poll takes place once yeah then we
elect representatives so i i
don't think there's anything
inconsistent about what it is no this is
also something that's important
sorry go ahead if you want me to speak
that's okay uh no it's fine it's just
that
i would prefer to speak more freely
without interruption
um i think that a very very large i'm
sorry do you feel like you've been
interrupted i feel like you've been
speaking quite a bit
i haven't been speaking i haven't been
able to respond i haven't been speaking
quite a bit but then you like
ask me a question and then i try to
respond and then i get cut off
i can let you speak after uh i'm just
finished with this little thought if you
so please
but um yeah but what i was saying is
that
we like people to uh you were saying
that certain things lie within
the jurisdiction for us to vote in and
then the president elects the supreme
court
what i'm saying is that there isn't
really so much of a difference between
us allah
that's not me interrupting when you're
misrepresenting what i've said i never
said the president elects the supreme
court
i never said the president elects the
supreme court so the president nominates
and the senate confirms and rejects you
elect i set a point
okay he nominates and the senate
confirms a rejects
absolutely okay um
um so what i was trying to get to was
the idea
that so obviously um
the pr when the president nominates uh
that's what
uh when the president nominates their
specific uh
whoever they see is the justice right um
and it has to go through the senate
um usu what the thought process is is
that
the senate um is usually mixed enough
and diverse enough to a point where it
can
represent um whatever the it can kind of
work as a media between the highest
power in the nation the president
and the people obviously because
the senate is something that we can vote
on directly
uh and so usually the logic is that okay
we
appoint my justice and they pass through
and they pass through
the senate and they go to the supreme
court can you clarify what you say i
appoint my justice who's i
uh if let's say that i'm the president
and i'm like who should i nominate as a
justice this is some random person
and then they go to the senate uh the
logic behind that is that
the president reelect is reflecting the
majority view of the country
at that specific time and so therefore
after that
i'm sorry i didn't hear that that's the
thing that was buzzing who is
representing the majority of you what
were you uh well the president
represents the majority
the uh the majority vote of the
electoral college
um and so therefore uh when they elect a
supreme court justice
uh that will be reflective let's if they
get appointed that will be reflected
of that specific uh whoever the
uh that'll be that'll be representative
of
uh whatever the people were feeling or
believing at that specific time
and so the justices actually are
if if you just get your head around that
the pres the justices are
representatives of the people
and being that they are representatives
it's their job to
represent the will of the administr of
whatever administration that may have
been which in turn is a representation
of
the majority at that specific time well
i wouldn't argue
i would argue that's incorrect and
really scary when combined with your
view of court packing because if you're
saying that the supreme court's job is
exclusively to represent
the specific justice field remember the
interrupting
do we need to put a time ticker on this
right now so people come on i've been
talking for a very long time
you've been talking for a very long time
and you've been very rude with
interrupting so let me finish what i am
saying i just let you go on for a long
amount of time
you can't demand respect and not offer
respect
well you don't need to talk to me like
i'm a child i would prefer if we have a
very level civil discipline we can but
can you stop interrupting
you just earlier requested that i
stopped interrupting while i wasn't and
you were interrupting absolutely
okay so my presupposition here is that
what you've just expressed is very scary
for a litany of reasons
and those reasons are when combined with
your idea of court packing and this
notion that the
job of a supreme court appointee is to
exclusively represent the view of the
executive
who nominated them that is why it is not
simply an
executive who uh actually elects them
which was the word that you used earlier
i think might have been a foreign use
the word elect and that's the one area
where i had to correct you
he can nominate and it can be confirmed
by the senate because the supreme court
is not meant to be a governing body it
is meant to be
exclusive separate and apart from the
house of congress from the senate
from the united states presidency to be
impartial it is not meant to represent
the majority will of the people it is
meant to interpret the constitution
and so if you have this ill-conceived
notion i would argue
that their job is to represent that of
the executive who nominated them
and that we should increase the number
of these people under
what the authority of an executive who
would nominate more that
is an absolute recipe for an
authoritarian
regime sure just as a quick aside before
i say anything else
i think that's pretty uh interesting
with your art and support of donald
trump who's
pretty starkly authoritarian however
really yeah uh
yeah we can get into that that's a
mischaracterization of my view do you
know what i support of donald trump and
what i don't
uh if i remember i only remember from
the 2016 election
uh however um lowering taxes
no new wars less regulation that's
authoritarian more freedom of speech
more right to bear arms
no that's not that doesn't fall under
the authoritarian verses
that doesn't fall between on the
authority accident well let's go back to
your argument then as opposed to
throwing out buzzwords okay because
that's not fair either if you want to be
respected
i would prefer if you didn't add a human
in me so what i was you literally just
said that's ironic that you support
donald trump as an
you need to hold authoritarian to the
same standard if you want to have an
adult absolutely
absolutely so um what i was saying
is that uh you mischaracterized my
argument a little bit
in that i was saying that the president
that it's a representative of the
president-elect
uh what i meant at this what i meant is
that obviously the nominee will be
appointed
by whoever is the president at a time
however they have to get through the
senate
and the senate works as the three
branches of government do well i guess
sort of um as it's intended to work
as i'm sorry i don't know what do you
mean yes that's kind of sort of i don't
understand
they're intended to work they don't
always work one way or the other
um for a new for numerous reasons
lobbying um
obviously thought uh biases that may be
there but
um when you have to elect a certain
individual through the senate
right uh or what am i saying oh when you
have to
when you want to get someone appointed
to the supreme court you have to send
them through the senate and that works
as a
balance which is meant and since they
are directly representative of the
or since the senate is a direct vote
from the people they should be
representative
of the people so therefore the senate is
yeah
so therefore that works as the center's
job is not to vote on a justice who's
most representative of the will of
people the senate's job
is to confirm is to confirm a justice
who will properly
adhere to and interpret the rule of the
constitution
let me ask you this uh because we've
been going back and forth we don't have
all the time in the world so let me ask
you a few pointed questions i would
appreciate if you answered them
absolutely
okay um first off how many justices
what's the number
uh how many just do we have right now we
have nine uh
so you're saying you're support packing
the courts what's the number what's the
cutoff
uh that i would prefer to be at for the
supreme court if you support
packing the courts how many justices
um or would you cap it at all or should
the next president just add more and
more and more
um no uh i think that just
increasing it marginally to perhaps um
it would have to be an odd number so
there would be a majority
uh to perhaps 13 or okay 13. if we
expand it to
15 that may be a bit much i think 13 is
a nice happy moment and then uh
and then some kind of congressional
mandate to stop it um
uh congressional mandate to perhaps uh
stop it unless people see it fit to
expand it at some point in the future
there could be unforeseen issues
happen in the future maybe some big
philosophical revolution happens and we
all realize
you know that maybe that's cool but yes
i believe that it should be
for the time being no more well that's
what we did and no less that's what we
did with the judicial act of
nine yep right in the coast civil war so
that's exactly why we did it and that's
why we have the number nine you just
think that there should be 13
or 15. so if donald trump is elected you
would support donald trump getting four
more justices
it doesn't it's in his constitutional
right if they pass through the senate
then
i can't do anything about that okay so
you wouldn't have a problem with that um
well i'm saying i wouldn't have a
problem with it disingenuous i may
disagree with the justice i probably
would describe the justices heal points
but if he does it and they get through
the senate obviously
they all will um most probably because
the senate is right
um then that's and i see i just that's
where we fundamentally disagree i don't
want donald trump to able to stack the
courts
thank god he has never even tried it he
has never implied that he would try it
uh because he believes i know you
mentioned an authoritarian but he's
actually limited the scope of government
in many ways matter of fact those are
the major grievances against donald
trump
is lowering taxes and lowering
regulations and supporting free speech
laws that
protect individual considerations no no
hold on let's continue let me finish
here
and then we go to this idea that you
believe for some reason even though
you're a political science
student that the supreme court's job is
to represent the will of the people as
opposed to interpret the constitution
let me ask you this
that the job actually of the senate the
president and the senate to confirm
justice and this is why there is a
precedent that's been set
of the incoming president releasing his
list of potential supreme court justices
i'm sure you're aware of this
donald trump did it he released another
list joe biden has not done it he said
you'll have to elect him to figure out
what's in there
right because the job is not simply to
pick people who are representative of
the majority will of the people
majority of the people one point
supported slavery doesn't mean that it's
right
majority of the people didn't
necessarily think that women should get
credit cards thank god an all-white male
supreme court
ruled that women should be able to get
credit cards right the credit card
authorization act
so my point is it's not just about the
majority of people it's about
interpreting
the constitution yeah that is the job of
the president in nominating that's why
he releases his list of potential
nominees
that is the job of the senate confirming
not confirming someone who will simply
answer to mob
rule and that is really a scary
preposition when you combine it with
this idea that
any president any executive going
forward can simply
add more seats and i don't think that
that's a system of government that's
functional i don't think that it's one
that's tenable and i think
thank god that we actually uh had even
though we didn't have a diverse
group according to your definition
diverse people in the supreme court
they made sure that there were equal
rights passed for women they made sure
that there were equal rights passed for
african-americans because
it didn't matter your personal point of
view what mattered was
constitutional interpretation and
individual liberty and uh it doesn't
mean we're always perfect but we
eventually got it right regardless of
color of skin or genitals hanging
between their legs
kit i appreciate it brother thank you so
much for taking the time i appreciate it
thank you
[Applause]
seems pretty cut and dry to me but what
do you think what's the best
case for why acb should not be confirmed
and is court packing
a legitimate strategy or just
underhanded partisanship and [ __ ]
as always sound off in the comments
below we will see you
in the next installment of change my
mind hey there youtube viewer if you
like this installment of changed my mind
click on one of these other installments
playing in a box it's the only way you
can find it because if you search it it
may not show up because it's
controversial and youtube wants to um
discourage that
the controversy to change my mind
play